good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday it is
you know I don't even know what day of
quarantine it is because all the days
have now just become one long period of
time it's day seven for me one full week
of the teen it's day like six since I
started taking it seriously how are you
doing I'm doing well um you know just
really it's it's crazy I feel like I
can't even fathom how long this is gonna
be you know yeah I keep trying to be
what people are calling optimistic but
I'm just like praying and hoping that
it's gonna be a few weeks but if it's
gonna be months and we're on day seven
you're them what are we gonna do
obviously this is also new for us so it
feels like it's harder than it actually
is but once you get into the rhythm of
life being quarantined I guess it's like
room you just get used to it I know when
like for the life of me I can't find
good content to watch even the books
that I had started weren't good and like
I just need I need a show like I was
talking to my friend Rebecca last night
and she was having the same problem as
me and I was like have you ever watched
Desperate Housewives she was like no and
I oh my god you have to watch I'm so
jealous of you that you have never seen
it it's about to rock your world when I
rewatched it a few years ago I did not
leave my house for a month jack and
that's exactly what I need to be doing
right now I rewatched it last year for
the first time in many many many years
and I was actually depressed when it was
over I haven't watched a good show since
then it ruined me yeah it can do that I
think I'm gonna start watching um
succession oh let me know what you think
did you ever watch it I watched like the
first episode or maybe the first two and
it just like didn't do it for me because
it was like all of like the money of
dynasty but none of the glamour yeah it
seems like a very grey show yeah it's
like a very gritty show but like there's
so much money like throw some sparkles
on it like a party I can't you can't
yell at that um but I did watch a little
bit of TV yesterday I actually have not
been watching as much TV as I thought it
would be but I watched The Real
Housewives of New Jersey part three
reunion we will recap that at the end of
the show and I also watched barely
lethal which was your selection for the
chest movie of the day and have a lot of
thoughts both positive and negative
great I look forward to hearing it I was
worried when I chose it but I just
thought it was
a movie that sort of like fell between
the cracks and I just wanted to
resurface it and I rewatched and I was
like oh this is a cute movie I wonder I
didn't hit you know what movie maybe I
mean what TV show we might watch it's
really not us and we never got it into
it but everyone like our age generation
like lives by Gilmore Girls yeah but I
never got into it and you know what I'm
tired of watching things from the 90s
like I need an iPhone so true because
then it's like they're emailing each
other or calling and I'm like send a
text drop a pin yeah like I can't
resolve this problem of the episode if
you just send an email or you just
dropped your PIN or it's dude find your
friends like I just can't relate I need
a 21st century show I totally agree did
you ever watch Friday Night Lights yes
fabulous fabulous that's actually a
great great show to binge right now if
you've never seen it it's fabulous
I think it's on Netflix yeah we're on
Hulu I pinched it like two years ago and
I had never seen it oh you know what
actually like maybe I could binge what
which with it like I should like it but
for some reason I never watched it will
in grace One Tree Hill oh you don't mean
either mm-hmm but it's that same thing
of like I know iPhone and I want to and
like getting involved in a show that is
still releasing new episodes but has
like oh I mean you know this this
quarantine would be an excellent time
for someone to start Grey's Anatomy from
the beginning because there's like 1
million episodes but I'm just it's not
my type of show thing I didn't know
thank you
also I can't keep having this thought
but I haven't mentioned it on the show
yet because I feel like a lot of
networks and streaming services like
really aren't capitalizing on the fact
that everyone is home buying TV like
right now like not one streaming service
has released a new season of a show or a
new show and like I'm sure maybe
something was meant to be bring them up
next week or in a month but like speed
it up ever you have all the eyeballs in
the world right now everyone would be
talking about the same show like I wish
Game of Thrones was still on yeah and we
could all be binge watching it together
it would get us from week to week uh-huh
I mean do you know how much it's killing
me that my [ __ ] comedy special isn't
being released for like two more months
no I need you guys I'd try if Netflix
has any movies on deck like put them out
now also I had a really good idea that
was just gonna say that because Real
Housewives of New York premieres next
week and like I know they expect us to
watch it once a week until the end of
time but I think what they should do if
anyone's listening over at Bravo what
would be a really fun activity is if
they release one episode every night and
like the season will go by faster but as
a country will be watching the Real
Housewives of New York Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday it's all will
be talking about fabulous and by the way
like I would I think that whatever
network
servus decided to do this would be like
regarded worldwide it's like one of this
genius marketers of our generation yeah
genius marketing and you're giving
people something to entertain them
during this time so you're not just like
profiteering from the quarantine but
you're also serving society and
entertaining and bringing good humor in
spirits speaking of society would
Netflix drop the next season please it's
been so long could Netflix please drop
the next season please oh my god I'm
that's one of the shows I'm most excited
about I wish that I had found it when
there was three seasons yeah but I'm
afraid it's gonna be like a Riverdale
when the first season is so phenomenal
and you fall in love with like the
teenage of it all and then it like it
just gets silly well yeah because it's
gonna get silly because they're gonna
run out of food and people are gonna
start killing each other silly and it's
just wildly they're wild and out and
well they might not run out of food
because they found farmable land I know
but are we ever gonna find out what
happened to them I don't know I think
that they're just stuck here now and
like every now and then they'll toy with
the idea of getting back reality but you
don't think so I mean something like
that I know people are saying Ozark is
back next week on Netflix the new season
like drop it this week drop it this week
I watched it I'm like the president I'll
be happy time I watched it and it's not
a present and I have literally never
hated Jason Bateman more and like he's
one of my favorite actors like be like
no funny everything that I like he just
happens to be in except for Ozark so I
know it's critically acclaimed and
everyone loves it but it's like really
great and a piece of [ __ ] yes sometimes
I'm like everyone loves this show I
would have to love it but I have no
interest in watching Ozark or mind
hunters or The Outsiders or West world
or zombies
what's the Walking Dead and and I feel
like we're really limited in what we can
watch our at least for me like I don't
feel like watching something really dark
or scary or about crime because like the
streets at night are scary like when I'm
walking Theo like I'm looking behind
I just I'm trying to keep it happy and
light yeah so that's a 50% of the shows
on Netflix I can't even watch because I
don't wanna watch another documentary
about like a serial murderer yeah so I
feel like all the shows that are happy
in light that are up my alley I've
already watched so I'm still watching
the build type hey you should you should
watch it I know you know actually I'm
saying I haven't had that much time to
watch TV I've weirdly been so busy
during this quarantine yeah me too
yesterday I filled my home to are
finally exact you don't I do it together
it's 20-minute video it's on our patreon
channel patreon.com/scishow
morning toast head over there watch it
we have a lot of other episodes and
video content over there if you do need
premium content at this time
speaking of premium content episode 2 of
maternity live is out now Olivia's
sitting down with her man's Zack Shapiro
and not only are they having a very cute
conversation but they are revealing the
gender of their bed Beth Jackie and I
listen to the episode yesterday it's so
cute if you love Olivia you're gonna
love this podcast we got to hear from
Zack on there's tons of actually new TNN
podcasts everyone released podcast this
week for the most part so you've a new
episode of mood with Lauren Elizabeth
featuring our good girl Jackie Oh a new
episode of Margaret's podcast which is
so pertinent cuz we're gonna talk about
Real Housewives of New Jersey reunion
Jackie and I were both on this week's
episode and the snapshot which jacket is
also on so we're changing the name of
TNN to jnn because it's Jackie's news
network no it's just when it rains it
pours you guys I haven't been on any of
these shows yet and then this week I'm
on all of them so and catch our lady
gang interview it was really funny we're
on their podcast this week and I got so
many gems from it because I was saying
how like I'm like so obsessed with what
people think about me I read every
single one of my TMS so so many people
do yeah me like I know you're reading
this oh that's so funny anything about
it really I saw like a few common I
guess cuz I mentioned my DMS yes why
people DM me I appreciate it I don't
know if it's a story but I did kind of
like change the world yesterday I don't
think it's a story so but it did make
the news thanks Us Weekly whatever
toaster works at Us Weekly like always
being supportive they go thank you so
much I did I made I made some headlines
cuz I had quite a viral live live show
last night 11,000 people please share
some of the highlights
well the highlights were I just went on
to shoot the [ __ ] like everyone was
going live and I was like sitting here
yesterday talking she had about
celebrities going live and like I did
one myself cuz I'm a hypocrite and I was
just like being bored and having fun and
it turned into this like hour-long fun
fest you know first Brad Goreski was
like let me on we got to talk about
Beverly Hills trailer so I brought him
on we had a great combo just about like
life Beverly Hills celebrities Real
Housewives
then he had to go and then I was just
shooting the [ __ ] with he have to go
there's nowhere to go
I don't know Gary was calling him or
something how cute and then I had a
bunch of toasters on I just wanted
people to come on it was like a town
show I want them to come on show me
their special talents so some girl was
waxing her lip
another girl did a somersault for me and
then it was just like so dramatic and
then Kelly was in my live stream yeah
and everyone's like Kelly on and it took
me two hours to figure out how
get her on like I was being a grandma
but she got on and oh sorry but before
that NIC vile came on right and I was
just shooting the [ __ ] with NIC vile and
they file through some you know much
more entertain at Hannah Brown and Tyler
Cameron because they're out and about
and yeah the world isn't ending when he
was signing off he was and this is what
got me written up in US Weekly when he
was signing off he was liked by everyone
stay safe don't make you know don't be
leaving your house you know making tic
TOCs and I'm like referring to someone
specifically he's like no but he's
obviously referring to the crew in
Florida who like are quarantined with
like 10 people and like constantly going
on about constantly on a boat at the
beach in the pool I get no yeah maybe
quarantine is different in Florida like
I guess if you have a pool in your house
like you do go but why go to the public
beach yeah and also like if you have a
pool you can go just like don't post
about a million times like not everyone
has a pool also if you have so many
followers and like so many people like
they're together right now they're so
influential right now like if you can't
want to go to the beach fine but like
don't post it everybody in the world was
acting that way it wouldn't be good
right Swede threw some shade at them and
then I also asked him about Kelly
because Chris Harrison was like Fanning
their flames on Instagram saying that
they were like dating getting cuddly and
Nick was like we spoke for two seconds
we're like just friends but she's a
great girl okay whatever and then Kelly
come on and amongst many things I asked
her why she wasn't at women tell all
she didn't really have a good answer
she's like honestly like I don't know
like I just wasn't asked to be there and
I said people said it was because you're
probably and she said that that's not
true I said it's because people people
said you're still with Peter she said
that's not true
and I'm like and because it's people are
saying that they like fired you
essentially because you were talking
about production therefore in violation
of your contract
she said that's also not true because
they invited her to after the final rose
so she didn't have a reason as to why
that is she said the only girl from her
season who she doesn't talk to his
Natasha and she just really felt like
Natasha didn't really like her that much
um and then when I asked her about Nick
vile she said um like everyone's been
asking her about it and she was like
whatever and I'm like would you date
anyone in bachelor nation and we were I
was naming people and and then I got to
Peter Krause and she like made a face
I'm like excuse me and she goes sorry my
phone fell and then she goes I mean like
he's so into my DMS I'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me that can't be me like
it should be you and now that I think
about it I think that this is what was
meant to happen for Peter Krause I agree
him and Kelly Flannigan and they can
Oh God Kelly crouch Chicago and
Wisconsin are super close are super
close I think they can make it work I
would love that
but I also love her and Nick Viall I
actually ship her with Peter a little
bit more I don't know I just ship
happiness that's what I should for
everyone
happiness and love for everyone I just
wish we could all get along like we used
to in middle school you don't even go
here no I just have a lot of feelings
okay are you ready I think it's time
even though we have absolutely no idea
if it's time because the clocks have
stopped working because there's no time
at all
like the present to let you know the
last five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and it's tied but
you know we've been saying all week
about how quarantine is really time to
take care of yourself and that includes
your vaginal health I'm sorry I'm gonna
say you guys and today's episode very
appropriately is brought to you by you
Cora you Cora and in 2014 you'll korres
founder Jenna got eight UTIs she knew
she couldn't stay in the cycle but she
found herself having the same dead-end
conversation about what she could do to
be more proactive this inspired her to
take matters into her own hands and
start you Cora with her partner Spencer
you Cora makes effective urinary tract
health products that allow you to
finally be proactive and help prevent
UTIs instead of treating it once she has
arrived it's time to move on from
cranberry juice try you Cora you mix a
packet of you Cora with a glass of water
and drink it after the deed it's easy
effective and tastes like pink lemonade
you Korres products are developed using
the best research available in
collaboration with the team of
physicians the unique drink mix and mix
flush mmm the unique drink mix flushes
and cleanses the urinary tract and also
boost your immune system which is
especially important in vulnerable
vulnerable moments like after sex
exercise or whatever else is a trigger
for you you Cora has helped over 65,000
people stay healthy and counting it's
kind of a genius product like why wait
for a UTI when you could just tell that
[ __ ] to get the [ __ ] out of here
and if you want to try it get proactive
about your urinary tract health with you
Cora
right now you Korra's offering 30% off
when you text morning to 64000 but hurry
because it's a limited time offer text
morning mor ni ng to 64000 to get 30%
off your order of you Cora that's
morning two six four zero zero zero love
it
sign on get your vaginal health right
first story in two
cringy of smooth yet gal gadot celebrity
imagine video is here the video that
nobody asked for is here to ruin your
day it's here to ruin your day so if you
haven't seen it yet we posted it to the
morning toast Instagram gal gadot
enlisted her celebrity friends to send
over very cringe-worthy videos of them
singing imagine and then she used iMovie
to put them together in a way that did
not transition well this is hard because
here's a prime example of someone who is
universally beloved gal gadot everyone
loves her she's wondering and she is the
face of feminism her and her female
director like shieff she hopped on the
scene and just was liked by everyone and
I think you know when when you get that
level of fame and that level of respect
from the world you think you can do no
wrong so you do insane things like put
together videos and I'm I'm reluctant to
say anything bad about Gaga chote but
like she needs to know I'm good I'm sure
she had good intentions making this
video I'm sure every celebrity who
participated thought they were doing
something great and gonna inspire the
world but the way that it came out was
just like a hot steaming pile of [ __ ]
mostly because nobody could sing yet no
but like all the keys were different
like the sounds the pauses it was just
not it was not it and they had no way of
knowing that but maybe they should have
made the video I mean like woo maybe
this is not what the world needs and
certain people really just went out of
their way to do a bad job and sabotage
the video Natalie Portman oh yeah there
were varying levels of effort but then I
felt sometimes like the people who were
exerting a lot of effort we're ruining
it as well yeah just as much as the
people who weren't trying to me the
people who did the most unoffensive jobs
were Jimmy Fallon and James Marsden like
singing Anki not necessarily the most
amazing but just singing at the right
tempo the right pitch and just singing
not yeah yeah everybody sang well and
everyone's saying pretty well
considering not all of them are singers
it was just the way that it was put
together it was like just crickets
cringe Central some of the celebrities
who have participated were Kristen Wiig
Jamie Dornan Mark Ruffalo Will Ferrell
Amy Adams zoe kravitz the only person
yet I was interested in in hearing and I
wish she just said
whole song with SIA and I just can't
believe that like see his name is now
like it involve dashed and it's crying
and you know what like as much as I love
respect and stand see it to the death
like this was shameful for her I really
was okay so put yourself in her shoes
gal gadot reaches out oh don't reaches
out and say [ __ ] I'm putting together
like a little celebrity compilation
video of all of us singing imagine just
to like inspire the world can I get a
tidbit from you
I don't know these celebrities knew what
they were involved in until they saw it
Jackie I've never been so happy to not
be a celebrity because of course you get
asked that they're gonna turn it down
yeah but are you an [ __ ]
yeah but it's just like this is the
level of this is why celebrities are so
out of touch like they think that this
is what we needed
look we're good no we're good and even
if this was brilliantly done we don't
need her no no we don't need her like I
don't feel inspired no this does not
change how I feel about my own situation
not at all here are some of the funniest
tweets from people you wonder what I am
grateful for the video because we have
something to talk about today like we've
literally been talking about coronavirus
for a week I'm not grateful for the
video because it was one of the first
things I saw when I woke up and like
that's just not the kind of energy I
needed going into this day it hardly
said it's hard enough to stay positive
in these times and then I see videos
like that and it just it makes me want
to give up it's crushed my spirits for
sure here are some of the funniest
tweets one just seen the celeb image
imagine video and now coronavirus no
longer scares me so maybe it was
productive you guys maybe just saw the
gal gadot imagine video thing and i
think maybe it ruined music for me ah
this is so cursed how did this even come
to happen do they have a GC and gal
gadot twas like hey you know what would
lift everyone's spirits an awkward
rendition I've imagined it's terrible
it's truly terrible but you know what
thanks but no thanks yeah we're just
gonna return to sender yeah we see the
effort we somewhat appreciate it but
we're good yeah have a good day next
story a little more coronavirus
cancellation postponement etc there's a
million stories we can do on it but the
one that stuck out to me is that la la'
Canon Randall Eman are postponing their
wedding amid the current a virus
outbreak I read about this very sad they
just can't have to break these two yeah
very sad their nuptials will take place
at the same place at the same place in
Newport Beach California but they are
postponing it it was supposed to be
April 18th Laos so soon and instead they
will be getting married in July that's
really sad did you see 50 cent is back
at it I I don't give he's annoying me
a flying [ __ ] about 50 no that as it
relates to Randall and Lala by the way
but when it happened I was interested
like I was living for the content I
thought it was an interesting celebrity
for you like very random but now it's
like months later stop softy stop I
think that he made like you got a lot of
followers and got a lot of press and a
lot of attention from that and I don't
think he's used to that and I think he's
trying to capitalize on it again to me
he's like an a-list rapper and the more
he just makes his whole narrative about
like taking down some reality stories
girl it's like oh yeah like no and Lola
doesn't deserve this
no I mean lalala deserves only the best
in the world I just need her and Randall
to like be married I need her to be mrs.
Emmett and now I have to wait a few more
months and I'm getting choked up I am
yeah it's just like like why it's
getting to us why this yeah I mean
there's so many postponements friends is
now that reunion special HBO max was
putting together is now being delayed
amongst a million other things it's just
I can't believe how this virus has taken
the world by storm yeah it's crazy crazy
crazy okay well next story Kylie Jenner
says pregnancy prepared her to stay
inside during the corona virus outbreak
as people across the world are adjusting
to a life indoors kylie is simply simply
sliding back into old routines as the
star points out on her Instagram story
quote my pregnancy prepared me for this
I didn't leave the house for months
that's no exaggeration the 22 year old
literally hid herself from public view
for much of her pregnancy only emerging
for the rare trip to in-and-out and
other low-key outings that's really true
and so crazy but I guess when we live in
Kylie's house like it's easy to be
quarantined when you have like a bowling
alley and a pony and you know a
guesthouse and a mini house for your
daughter all I really want in these
Korona times and like when I see other
people posting and it makes me jealous
obviously a pool would be nice but a
fireplace yeah I wish I had a fireplace
when I like someone's story and they're
vibing an indoor or outdoor I was even
when I was watching Heartbreakers with
snitch and they were in that tacky hotel
room I was like that looks like a nice
room it has a fireplace I know I really
I
I've been missing I think more pool like
it that's why maybe that's why I'm like
talking down about Hannah Brown and
Tyler so you cuz I'm just jealous of
their pool like if I had a house I don't
know see I was having this conversation
with Ben last night what what do you
think is easier to be quarantined in a
small apartment but in the city like
like pharmacies and bodegas are still
little bit like you go downstairs run
and grab something a bag of M&Ms like if
you're craving something you do have
that accessibility or you could be in a
house where you can't really go anywhere
but you have more places you have a pool
you have an attic with a built like a
billiard stand you have a bigger kitchen
where you've been storing snacks for
years it's like Jack's mom's pantry I
was the second me and Ben started
stocking up I was thinking about sacks
mom's pantry Zach's mom
Jackie's husband's mom in Dallas like
has this beautiful house and it has the
most beautiful pantry I've ever seen in
my life like you could step into it and
it's filled with every snack you could
probably fit like five people in the
pantry oh my god it's so stellar and she
has such good taste inside she's a great
pool too and that that made me want to
be in house so I don't know what I would
prefer like I like that like you and I
can still technically do our job and
mm-hmm
if I needed it like Advil like I
couldn't go to Duane Reade and for the
most part bodegas pharmacies drugstores
are still open and fully functioning so
I don't know yeah they would love a pool
I think there's pros and cons but
overall I would love to be in a house
and I'd love to be together as a family
like we oh I'm not hanging out and not
seeing each other no and I'm seeing like
all these families on tik-tok like
playing board games and Mike Warren like
the quarantine fashion like family
edition and I just we don't have that ya
know we don't have that at all and it's
very upsetting and um that's why the
deer toasters yesterday I think hit us
really hard that girl was complaining
about her parents just like wanting to
hang out with her and like we're all
apart and like I cannot get Ben to hang
out with me like for the life of me oh
yeah same but I don't want to disturb
the peace but th EO is sleeping on your
lap like you have no it from my purview
I've never seen something so cute in my
whole [ __ ] life he's such an should
take a photo of that sometimes like I
can't believe you have such a precious
angel and I was really like it cute I
kind of need it so cute hold on smile so
[ __ ] cute oh my god okay done I wish
I could drop a photo in the youtubes
like stream chats but I can okay so if
you listening as a podcast and you're
working from home join us on YouTube
like we're having so much fun over here
how many of you have
the transition but it's so much fun over
here even I was talking to Rebecca last
night Becky from the redheads and she
listens to the podcast every day and I
was like you should be watching YouTube
this week even though like you like
podcasts like we're just better on
YouTube yeah and if you are watching on
YouTube please subscribe I really want
more subscribers like maybe make a
second account and subscribe twice I
would be really appreciative thank you
nice okay
next story a little bit of Christmas
cheer this is a twofer because one
people are putting their Christmas
lights back up to spread cheer amid the
corona virus pandemic I [ __ ] love
this so much love and to hallmark has
announced that they will be running
Christmas movies on Hallmark because
it's kind of having to Christmas all
over again
I mean I can leave nobody thought of
this sooner like obviously this is the
first network to capitalize YES on the
fact that everyone's home yes love that
for them very forward-thinking Christmas
is the only the Christmas spirit and
Christmas cheer is is everything we need
right now but I just want to say like if
I were to be really annoying I would say
that people putting up their Christmas
trees aren't going outside and they
should be staying inside be it to go
outside to put up your Christmas light
you can stay on your perimeter it's just
like going in your pool I'm just saying
anything no one's saying of to scale
like in the four walls of your house
below stay apart from other people as
long as you're not like getting the
whole neighborhood to help you put up
the lights put up their [ __ ] lights
man yeah so kudos to Hallmark for being
really forward-thinking I'm really proud
of them know who else put up her
Christmas lights
snitch I saw a man Margo was turning
into a true tick-tock er all these tick
tock kids bought these lights on Amazon
it if you want to go viral like you have
to be in your bedroom with the lights
off and with these like colored lights
on to give this like mystique like aura
yeah and you tape them to like the
ceiling of your room and they like meet
in the corners and they make a square
around the perimeter and Margo got them
I think they're so awesome I know I'm
kind of jealous now I'm trying to think
of ways that I could spread Christmas
cheer in my house like maybe some
festive knickknacks said maybe I'll put
the Kiley Holiday Collection back in the
middle of my coffee table
yeah um maybe I'll like light a
Christmas cookie scented candle I know
how I'm gonna start um spreading
Christmas cheer in my house I'm gonna go
caroling door-to-door oh and is the
season to be toasty la la la la la that
was not planned but like not playing we
toasted our hearts and
surprised like that I didn't even look
at you I wasn't even surprised Wow okay
well I love to see this if you have
Christmas lights and you have a house
like one I'm jealous to put them up yeah
Christmas lights are so like those are
the things like I've never disliked
being Jewish I really have always felt
that I was chosen to be a Jew and I take
that really really seriously and I
totally respect all of it but when I
like drive through suburban
neighborhoods at night and like
Christmas trees are like lit ablaze in
their yards and there's two sites
everywhere like that makes me sad and
that's when I'm like I wish I was like a
religious Catholic that's when I'm like
joy to the world the far Cheers
the bad
[Music]
much much much much yeah I feel you yeah
I'm something really interesting about
my live stream yesterday is that I got
to FaceTime with so many toasters and
they were just like literally lying
around in their toasts March I couldn't
even tell them to put it on to see it
but it's just so funny how we is so much
toasty lingo and people use it they like
consistently we're using it incorrectly
and I just really appreciate it like
some girl was like sharing me her dog
and she was like look at my farm
chairman I'm like no it's for chairman
and a farm chairman it's a type of house
but I like we understand that
intricacies but like I don't know if
everyone does a farm chairman is a type
of house and it's also foot time and
when he's on a farm yeah but it's also a
farm chairman is a type of house for for
chairman it's also a vibe like when
we're in a rustic situation that place
its farm chairman vibes so it's just I'm
so glad people are using the lingo but
they are also using it incorrectly and
I'm not behind no it was so funny I
didn't even correct her that's really
funny
okay bit some final story I feel like
this is something on his kind of gun
unlike knock'em that much attention
because of obviously coronavirus but
Utah had a very big earthquake well if
you watched my live stream you would
know that because I had a Mormon not a
Mormon I had a Freudian slip
I had a toaster I had a toaster on the
ground in Salt Lake City and she was
telling me all about it
yeah buildings have been damaged but no
major injuries as the state braces for
days of aftershocks there was - yes so
there was a second one yesterday but it
was just like a little small jilt mm-hmm
a magnitude 5.7 earthquake struck magma
at 7:09 a.m. on Wednesday March 18th
shaking homes from Logan down to Utah
County it was a stage largest since in
1992 earthquake in st. George Wow just
like what's going on well I don't know
it's like the biblical plagues hmm the
earth-shattering
very shook worthy literally very shook
were they calling earthquakes earth
shook shook quake or like shook to the
quake yeah yeah that's good that's good
anyways if you're Utah toast or or even
if you're not a toaster we're sending
you our love yeah but we're sending the
toasters a little bit more love for sure
I have an ad is that okay with you
I would love it because you know what
this show isn't for is free so we're not
ladies and gentlemen let me take a quick
moment to let you know that today's
episode is
to you by fiber let's talk about finding
freelance talent for your business or
project finding the right freelancer can
be time-consuming frustrating and
expensive where do you go to find the
talent how much will it cost how can you
be certain that they'll deliver thanks
to Fiverr
finding the right freelancer doesn't
have to be a struggle we have had a
great experience using Fiverr we're
constantly hiring graphic designers
video editors and to be honest I had no
idea where you find freelancers and then
fibre came about and changed my life
their marketplace helps you get more
done with less so they connect you with
business they connect businesses with
freelancers who offer hundreds of
digital services including graphic
design copywriting and programming film
editing way more find what you're
looking for instantly so you go on five
or you could search by their service by
a deadline by price by reviews and more
you know exactly what you're paying for
up front there's no new oshi Asian need
in and they have 24/7 customer service
they connect you with quality talent
that you can count on sellers have
worked with some of the most influential
brands in the world finding talent for
your project has never been easier
reviews seller ratings buy your feedback
and select the right freelancer based on
your budget take five and check out
fibre and calm and you will receive 10%
off your first order by using our code
toast it's so easy don't waste any more
time and get the service you deserve by
going to F IV e
is toast fiber it starts here thank you
find great talented people there's some
people in the youtubes just like making
a lot of noise hypotheses as to why I'm
not wearing my engagement ring and
wedding ring and it's because Ben and I
got into a fight and I'm totally kidding
I wore them two days ago and if you
watch episode I didn't stop touching him
they were bothering me so much and then
yesterday I sat down and they were
bothering me again so I just took them
off and decided not to wear them today I
think it has to do with all the hand
washing that I'm ik scraping my skin
against my rings yeah the past two days
I think I forgot to wear my rings it's
like I'm just trying to get out of the
house and like get my makeup done and
look semi cute and like this unknown
world like sometimes I forget my rings
ya know so I'm still married the
quarantine has not taken that from me
yet but it has taken the health of my
nails oh yeah and my eyebrows I actually
sat in bed and plucked my eyebrows last
night it hurts so bad I had to do
something and my moustache was wanna get
like an at-home waxing kit I need to wax
my armpits so again if you watched my
livestream last night some girl was
about
her life and she was using these strips
like you heat them up in your hand um
and I did it was a little blurry but it
looked like it worked yeah maybe I'll
order something from Amazon yeah not
don't get one of those like it's like
melt yourself that's dangerous okay
there was actually a in 2020 like there
should be good at home waxing kids there
was a shark tank when Bethenny was on
that know most - thing yeah use it on
your arm and Bethenny invested in it I
never heard more about it but that would
be a good thing for right now
yeah but it's just like for my underarms
I wish when I got a manicure this
awesome manicure that I got hombre that
I just got a gel like where was it you
know right no oh yeah no I'm actually
like grateful because I've been needing
to like having no polish on my nails and
let my nails grow and like get healthy
but I can never do that if I have like
living my life normally because who
wants to talk to a girl with no paint on
her and I was like she's disgusting so
no one's actually seeing my nails right
now except for oh five million of you
also except with you but he doesn't
judge no he does not judge let's dive
into our recaps all the things we're
watching um new jersey finale was last
night part three of the reunion Joe
Gorga like came back out alone we was so
here like the transition but there were
two things that I loved about this
reunion one is that for the first time
in my life I actually saw Teresa
apologize genuinely and take
accountability and she got up no one
even went up she got up and gave
Margaret a hug like what she did was so
disgraceful um but again if someone
genuinely apologizes and owns and is
accountable for their actions like I
have no choice in the moment to accept
it and see if they change yeah and I
really felt like she meant her apology
and she was bothering me for the whole
reunion but that moment I actually
appreciated it
and it was right after they were talking
more about like Joe and ice and you just
get and you're like you literally can't
be mad at Teresa like when she was just
talking about like moving on from Joe
and the divorce and it's like now now
Teresa is like the primary earner in the
family and they were all saying they
think that he's gonna start asking for
spousal support which would just be
devastating because Teresa literally
saved the family and she paid over a
million dollars for Joe and back taxes
and restitution so that would be
devastating but Melissa and Joe were
just like now being more vocal about
yeah they were not holding back
especially I feel like Joe we always
assumed how he felt but like Melissa
like took that on as well yeah um but
it's nice that we can just like talk
openly you know about the elephant in
the room now that they are getting
divorce
and Dolores - it was just like it must
be so hard to watch her friend go
through that and like when that is your
husband and like father of her children
it's like you can only say so much right
um but now that like cats out of the bag
and they're getting divorced like I feel
like everyone felt good about saying
their piece
yeah the reunion um did not feature one
word from Jennifer or Jackie it was
crazy like they literally do not speak
two words I guess it's like all the og
stuff yeah I'm like old like be like the
family that's the thing about Real
Housewives of New Jersey it's really
like a family reality show as opposed to
just like an ensemble cast and like that
used to be more the case when it was
like really Melissa Teresa and they had
Kathy and the cousins and everything
Rosie um but now it's it's more back to
housewives but there is still that like
this is family drama
yeah the second thing that I absolutely
loved about it was that not only did
they not give Danielle the seat next to
Andy and Andy came into her dressing
room and explained you can't be next to
reset and you can't be next Margaret so
we can't move them so she accepted her
fate and so not only did she get not get
to sit next to Andy she didn't get to
sit on the couch did literally put her
in a folding chair on the side and she
was so poorly lit like there was a huge
shadow on her face it was so
disrespectful like I was living for him
he's got a different show she's on her
own Island she talks such a big game if
I don't get that seat him I'm not doing
and he comes in you can't have that seat
let me know what you decide to do two
seconds and then and then at the end and
he was like I have a feeling this won't
be the last we see of you she goes - me
neither
even though she's been saying this whole
time that this is it she's never coming
back you're never gonna see her again
Danielle Staub the farewell tour you
know what I found to be the craziest
part of the episode that was sort of
glazed over what happened to Oliver he's
our tree gauge and then she like checked
him into an institution and ran no I
like that was such a weird time she was
like engaged she was gonna be in touch
issues gonna be higher than the countess
she was stepping out getting paparazzi
with her new man by the jet then dead
silence and then we watched his show and
she's trying to get back with Marty like
what did she do to this guy does anyone
have any proof that like he's well I
don't know and it was just so glazed
over in the actual season too because
there was more to it with that other
girl
Oliver's ex there was so much that we
never got more on it
actually would've loved a whole spin-off
on that and so I Everett leave she like
checked him into a facility but Angie
really pressed her about it like she was
like I don't really want to you know
talk about it oh she said that about
when she they had asked like how can you
and Marty live in the same house when
like you accused him of abusing your
daughters and she was like oh I don't
want to talk about that he's like but
you did say that but you put that out
you get about it so let's talk about it
yeah she was she just came out swinging
especially for Margaret who I feel very
protective over her but Margaret did a
great job of defending herself and it's
it's easy it's I mean to be in tenuous
position it's like my worst nightmare
like no even Teresa her her one life
raft was just beyond she was not totally
done with Danielle she was like and he
said after like now seeing at the end of
the season like do you regret defending
Danielle so much his entire season and
she said yeah like that was just like
the nail in the coffin for their
friendship it was really beautiful to
see and we have no choice but to live
for it yeah we don't have a choice we
don't that's the end of Jersey they are
filming now so I don't know when they
come back but meet New York in Beverly
Hills coming up the Beverly Hills
trailer yet oh my god it's fabulous
like literally fabulosity I love the
cast pictures in neon vibe they really
know how to just serve you know if you
watched my Instagram livestream
yesterday that's why I had Brad Goreski
on I was asking him like what he thought
about the whole neon theme he said it
was so fabulous and so on-trend the neon
is so hot right now yeah so Hari
I loved the neon I loved the new cast
pictures in the trailer everyone was
just so fabulous like the clothes the
trips and planes like it was just luxury
like it really is a whole different
level of housewives like it's just it's
sickening and we saw Garcelle and was so
sudden she gets into it with Teddy she's
like Teddy you're a little boring and it
seems like Teddy is actually involved in
a lot of drama this season but I think
the big culmination at the end is this
whole Brandi Glanville um
Denise Richards argument where I'm not
entirely sure what happens but I believe
it leads to Denise like being done with
the group forever but we'll see Wow
we will see I wish they would like move
up the premiere of it as well because we
need content and like I just feel like
it'd be great for everyone the bigger
role and the network and they go to the
trevi fountain and it's like so lizzie
mcguire oh my god that is so Lizzie yeah
it's it's fabulous and to read is there
just like with her Chanel collared shirt
like she there's obviously an important
event because they keep the trailer was
like filled with so many scenes from
this one dinner
she's wearing this fabulous Chanel
blouse like it the whole thing is just I
there's actually no other word to
describe it other than just fabulous wow
I'm so excited I'm gonna watch you but I
just didn't want to watch it on my phone
you know how I am yeah I think I watch
it on my computer so it was pretty
premium nice nobody else is premium my
Home Tour over at patreon.com slash the
morning toast and you know what else is
premium this new thing we're doing it's
called toast movie of the day if you
want to get involved you're new here we
used to do a segment called toast movie
of the week where we were to sign a
movie and then we'd recap the next week
but it just kind of fell through but
since everyone's watching so much
television this week we thought it would
be pertinent instead of doing toast
movie of the week we decided to do toast
movie of the day so yesterday Jackie
chose movie for the group barely liesl a
very low-key movie starring Hailee
Steinfeld sophie turner Doug Cameron
Jessica Alba samuel l.jackson steve-o
the guy from Project a steve-o steve-o
was the guy who came in with those like
electrolysis clamps when they were
torturing
Hailee Steinfeld oh very very random
yeah I mean I have a lot of thoughts
about it's just like your classic
rom-com except that no one ever had seen
it it's not Ron Cutler it's not your
classic Ron Cameron fuller is in it it's
me it's a made-for-tv movie that ends in
a love story it's not a rom-com and I
just thought it was a really cute film
just with all my themes let me just
start out by saying that that movie
falls into a genre a film that is your
favorite and is actually my least
favorite like silly dumb like teen
romance high school no no I love teen
romance high school it's more like a
hallmark movie where it's like bad
acting bad sets but that the acting was
fabulous okay so that's my problem here
is I needed to put two and two together
because there were parts of the movie I
actually really enjoyed like I thought
the high school stuff was so cute and I
do I love a high school drama the action
part was so stupid but yes parts of it I
really did like but I couldn't really
get into it at all because of one major
factor and that was the travesty that
was Hailee Steinfeld's acting like so
bad and then I just got me thinking
because Hailee Steinfeld's has had such
a weird career she launched onto the
scene at the Oscars because she was in
an oscar-winning film True Grit I
believe she was even nominated and she
was nominee she was like nine years old
she was a big deal and I looked it up
and that was in 2010 okay so in 2010 she
comes on the scene she's this like
prolific prodigy actor because she's so
young she's at the Oscar
and then you know she became a pop star
which is so weird but she was really
this well-respected actress and then I'm
shook to find out that this movie that
we just watched came out in 2015 so five
years later five years of more acting
after the Oscars this is an oscar-worthy
performance like well not Oscar nobody
this is the this is the performance by
an oscar-worthy actor well it makes
sense like a lot of the movies that she
did during this time like she did the
pitch-perfect sequel she did so
difference I thought she was age of 17
where she actually plays the exact same
character as in this movie it's just the
circumstances are different age of 17 is
fabulous she was just trying like I
think Paige perfect probably came after
and she was just trying to become like
that rom-com girl I think people
probably expected this movie to do a lot
better than it did I think it made like
less than a million dollars at the box
office but like is it ever in theaters I
don't know but if it had ever done
really well it would have been like you
know they obviously a plan for it to do
well it had such a big cash yeah I mean
it was very politically incorrect at
times like literally when they were
fighting at the prom with Sansa she goes
caught it she was calling her cottage
cheese thighs like certain things of it
were incredibly out of touch it didn't
age well at all but um and I don't want
to be so negatively Turner it's such a
good actress and like if a sophie Turner
is a serious actress takes herself very
seriously like she's an x-men she's in
Game of Thrones I think that she signed
on for this movie like thinking it was
gonna be a hit like who doesn't wanna be
a part of a hit movie yeah there was so
something about it that had that home
are quality that makes certain hallmark
movies unwatchable it's like that bad
film but it's all it's a genre like and
and you love those types of movies but I
it's like bringing back tears Mac
exactly yeah exactly um also dove
Cameron was there oh well she was good
she she's a good actress she also takes
herself so seriously the hair was not it
and I think that really I think that if
I had to attest the failure of the movie
to one thing it would be dove Cameron's
hair because like the color and the
styles the [ __ ] terrible but but it
really um it was like method acting
because the hair really set the tone for
what kind of girl she was like I think I
was having a hard time figuring out like
why she was being so mean but the hair
really spoke to me she's like mad cos of
her hair yeah that was it that was it
Cameron Fuller's cameo which I totally
missed until you pointed out was so
funny and crazy yeah
and I love that for him yeah me too so I
just thought it looks like a fun movie I
feel like if it came out like now on
Netflix it would be way different than
the way it came out five years and then
the storyline was kind of interesting
like her hiding from if the whole the
same cast of the same plot maybe a few
edits to the script wardrobe hair and
makeup and they put it on Eric's hair
and they put it on Netflix it could be a
smash yeah and like when she's walking
down first of all that outfit she wore
to school the first day all the office
was so terrible but the research that
she did to go to high school she watch
all the right move OC that was
hysterical like she's like all my
research has led me to indicate that you
are actually then I like I should try
out to be the mascot like there were
things about it that were really like
well done and redeeming and to me this
is like a rough draft but when she
walked down the school hallway and that
guy slaps your ass the [ __ ] not that's
not cool that's not it so and then he
winds up dating her sister right and by
the way of course that they ended up
being one big happy family and the mom
who was so cute and nice the mom is the
mom from good luck charlie on Disney
Channel never forget such a good job
never forget and I think also for dub
Cameron this was during her live in Madi
days and so that might explain the hair
maybe he wasn't allowed to change her
hair maybe yeah but really sophie Turner
is an incredible actress like she made
the most about her hair was so long I
know she's so doll she's amazing like
the action stuff in the beginning like I
was almost gonna turn it off like that
the whole Prescott school of boys
Preston whatever like that it was
killing me like it was so [ __ ] stupid
but it was it was good it was also for a
movie so silly like it should not have
been more than an hour and twenty
minutes and it was an hour forty five it
felt like thirty minutes too long okay
well I think it was a fun choice for
toast movie of the day one of my
favorite scenes was when the
cheerleaders went up turned they were
like being really nice they were so nice
that made me mad yeah but then she was
like oh my research Lizzie and indicate
that I should not be talking to you it
was really funny yeah so yeah it had its
moments it had its moments
I am I feel good about my choice I'm
definitely better than the invention of
lying so I feel like we can only go up
from there yeah well I just I do want to
put out there that the invention of
lying was your choice it was both of
ours meet like we both of you brought up
and I agree yeah and yes
we were like yes meat and then I juice
Heartbreakers which everyone loved and
I'm choosing today's and I think the
people are gonna like it
okay what is today's toasts also I of
the day I put it to a vote
on my Instagram so I just want to see
what the people voted it was between two
extraordinary films that I haven't seen
in a really long time on the first was
superstar
starring Will Ferrell and Molly Shannon
and then another Will Ferrell movie the
second option was a night at the Roxbury
which I think is less popular but super
star one by two thousand votes so it is
what it is super star it's they're both
on Netflix if you want to watch the
other one like later it's a good one but
super stars on Netflix it is the
weirdest movie ever I I watched it a
million times as a kid and I don't think
I probably understood half of it but all
I remember was her like making out with
trees and it was so funny yeah and it
smells Shannon's finest work and what my
parents didn't need me after bottled
water there are actually so many iconic
lines that movie there are ok I'm
actually excited about it it's on
Netflix I don't know if it's on Canadian
sorry guys but yeah I mean it's we
wouldn't even know how to cross
reference yeah I would even know how to
check yeah like Netflix dot CA unclear
um yeah it's a good movie like not
totally we don't seem excited I'm not
like I'm just so sick of watching these
old movies I really want to watch
something I've never seen because I've
realized I'm spending so much time in my
phone like my phone activity is up like
3000 percent find something else's the
more I watch movies I've already seen
the more I don't pay attention like if I
need to get sucked into the plot let's
find something to me I want you to be
happy I want to be happy let's go to
Netflix okay wait here how many
blockbusters he's just not that into you
Valentine's Day about that new Pete
Davidson movie oh oh oh thanks time
adolescent yes Ben's friend was just
telling me about it he said it was
phenomenal and he wanted to suggest it
for this but I don't think it's on
Netflix it's on Hulu yes but I said that
wasn't okay whereas on Netflix sleepover
that also came up with Ben's friends
there I asked him for recommendations so
okay what should we maybe one of us
should watch one one of us should watch
yeah there no let's just
I like the formula we're moving
currently at okay so which one you
choose what was the other one cold
big-time adolescence let me get let me
read a brief synopsis big-time
adolescence whoo oh my god you know it
would be an amazing movie to watch I
just watched it though a drug-dealing
college dropout becomes a mentor to
best friend a straight-laced teen who
idolizes him what I heard was good well
boy are you gonna say New York a minute
that night shall we watch it it's so
[ __ ] good fabulous film but I think
what we have is better okay wait what do
we have
super star or big time adolescence okay
it's like what do we want this movie
club to be movies we just haven't seen
in a while or brand-new movies I hate
watching new movies and I love watching
[ __ ] I've already seen no but I'm
feeling like now after watching three
movies I've already seen what I want I
want to watch something I have okay so
if we switch to Hulu do you think that
everyone will be able to oh yeah I mean
I think it's it's good to switch it up
not everyone has Netflix if you have if
you have a Hulu account share it with
your fellow tourists fellow toaster but
i jus want to see our people please not
superstar no the Rockstar is the best
movie oh they want us to do sleepover
but no no no ok you guys we need a
minute to find a movie I just feel like
everyone no matter what we say like it's
gonna be negative people are different
choice so but it just has to be
something that we're excited about
because either way people won't be happy
so at least like we'll be excited yeah
I'm not like Oh Machine Gun Kelly is in
this movie Big Time adolescence Sydney
Sweeney I don't know her I don't know
anyone in this movie so Anna Karenina oh
stop this is what the New York Times
says about Big Time adolescence it's a
feel-good movie okay that's helpful
thank you okay let's do it
big-time adolescence big-time
adolescence I can't tell if people are
happy or not I don't know because
they're like no yes I'm like - what okay
it's are we gonna do it there yeah I
wanna watch something I haven't seen so
big-time adolescence it is but then the
movies that I really want to watch um
[ __ ] the one that one parasite you asked
me to you have to buy it and so I wanted
everyone by at least okay so if you have
a Hulu account great if not you're in
the toaster group get someone's Hulu
everyone share your Hulu account I use I
don't even pay for Hulu I use a toaster
named Liz hi thanks let's do the best I
made my own profile I'm tell your sister
Madison I say hi so get on Hulu share
with your friends if you have one we're
gonna watch big-time adolescence new
original movie from Hulu starring Pete
Davidson
Machine Gun Kelly makes a little cameo
which is exciting they're happy okay
they're happy the people are happy
thinking wow that was a roller coaster
and I'm still watching the bowl type I
just made to season 2 if you're watching
wrong with me check out my thoughts on
my story you're above that I'd never H
watch it I think your stories are so
funny oh my god Thanks and Rebecca
called me to say that she just she told
me to watch the bowl type and she said
that she just watched my story like my
rant and that I was so on point it never
even occurred to her that they should be
fired and I think the reason why I like
feel so strongly about this show is
because they were working like in a
newsroom for a digital publisher and
like that used to be my job and so I'm
just like it's I'm so close to it yeah
and it really is pretty on the nose
except for the part where like any time
they have a personal issue they deal
with it in the office and they take all
their phone calls and face times from
their desks and talk about how they
wouldn't mind being laid off in front of
their other co-workers who might be
getting laid off like if you die from
that it's pretty on the nose yeah it's
on the nose you are the mole type why
would you say that because he said it
you you you really twit no like I I like
myself what's the word like I
self-loathing ly relate to it yeah yeah
yeah like you that's a dark time of your
life like let's not talk about it yeah
it's just like it brings me back and
they say I'd rather be here okay well
that is our show for you if you're
looking for more content follow totes
news network because there was a ton of
new shows this week that we mentioned
earlier and if you need to even more
content head over to our patreon channel
which is our premium subscription you
could pay eight dollars to get five
extra episodes a month we do some vlogs
some podcasts we've two more coming out
this month Jack you just did her Home
Tour there the link is
patreon.com/scishow morning toast
join us and thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and we're
podcasts can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I Heart
Radio cash box all the places whoever
you listen to podcasts find us the
morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are thank you guys so much
we'll see you on Friday Morrow to Maura